there are also two promising
developments this morning that we want
to get you in the race to find a vaccine
for the corona virus Charlie d'Agata has
that part of the story two frontrunners
in the hunt for the vaccine both
reporting great strides the us-backed
oxford university project announced its
rapidly expanding human testing the plan
vaccinate 10,000 260 people across
Britain including children aged 5 to 12
volunteers over 70 and frontline health
care workers the really critical
question though is whether the vaccine
protects people and of course we can
only address that question once enough
cases have occurred in the clinical
trial here's how it works
genetic material from the corona virus
is injected into a weakened version of
the common cold virus the modified virus
mimics kovat 19 kick-starting the immune
system to attack if the real kovat
enters the body from the original
epicenter china scientists using a
similar vaccine method report promising
results to in tests on a hundred eight
volunteers can see no biologics say
researchers identified immune responses
including antibodies needed to ward off
kovat infection they may be competing
but in the race to find a vaccine even
researchers say they hope there's more
than one winner for CBS this morning
Saturday Charlie d'Agata London